i wanna i gotta i wanna pull this story
up who will be our next president
it has not even been a day and the media
is
already salivating at the thought of joe
biden dying
well that's why that's why he was jesus
dead and ascent that's why he was
ascending they want him dead
ascending okay hold on hold on quartz
routes writes the story
what happens if joe biden dies in office
seriously guys
it's not even been a day the dude just
got in but we knew that was the game the
whole time
they wanted kamala harris to be the
nominee and tulsi gabbard
dropped a gravity bomb and wiped out her
campaign
so joe biden was their only hope and
then they had that funny play where all
the democrats drop out and endorse joe
biden
that was the only choice that joe biden
was able to beat bernie sanders
and so as soon as it happens i'm willing
to bet they wrote this story
before they were sitting on it yeah they
were waiting here's it from quartz what
happens if joe biden dies in office
as of noon today jos joseph robinette
biden
jr is the 46th president of the u.s see
how it's written
as of noon today as if they wrote it
before he was president is robinette
actually bob is he joe bob biden
no better than that he's joe bob jr yeah
he's joe bob jr
i mean that actually kind of sounds
endearing so it does a little bit joe
bob
jr they say he is the oldest joe bobs so
so here's what's funny at the
inauguration
joe biden was older than all of the
former presidents who were there
watching this not combined no no no but
like you had obama bush
and clinton and joe biden's older than
all of them whoa
i'm i'm pretty sure he's older than bill
clinton right yeah he is that's crazy
yeah
he's older and bill clinton was like
falling asleep did you see that
bill clinton fell asleep and he's like
well they say it was the greatest
inauguration speech ever given
well bill clinton fell asleep so i guess
he's a old guy anyway they say
he's the oldest president to serve the
country at 78. he is even older
than the older the older president to
leave office ronald reagan
who was still 77 for a few days and
reagan lost his mind
he thought that's that that movie what
was it well that movie was real
you know we've talked about that where
the the computer because it's going to
fire the war games
yeah you thought it was real something
like that the only winning
move is not to play right right
[Laughter]
anyway why do they have to write an
article about it we know what the answer
to the question is
well here's what they say they say 78
and that is almost two years older than
the current life expectancy of a u.s
born male
which is 76.3 and declining the lowest
of all wealthy countries and 14 years
older than the male life expectancy of
an american born in 1942
his life expectancy is 14 years above
people born in the same year as him he's
probably already dead
well so you know what's really funny uh
because i said this as a joke
they locked down all of dc yeah because
the inauguration actually happened weeks
ago
it was recorded and they can't let
anyone see i'm kidding by the way well
he's been in political office for
44 years seven uh 47 or 47.
47. well again almost 50 years now and
and i see a lot of people tweeting
he's going to fix things he's going to
change things that i'm like
huh when when joe biden first got
elected there were people serving in the
senate who were born in the 1800s
i i don't know if that fact-checked me
because i saw that on twitter from a
journalist they said
yeah that makes sense they were talking
about how joe biden was like one of he
was one of the youngest or the youngest
of the time
center to get elected 47 years ago and
there were people
who had been born in the late 1800s who
are still serving
isn't that crazy and they gave him the
nuclear football today
yeah another sensationalistic garbage
story that we saw in the mainstream
media was
donald trump stealing the nuclear
football and other left-wing twitter
personalities
but real real actual trump derangement
syndrome talking about i think he's
going to set off some nukes before he
goes
literally that's the hyperbolic
fear-mongering paranoia disinformation
nonsense that was out there today the
sun published that
trump had taken the nuclear football
with him to florida
and so i tweeted out the story like wow
and then i saw the video of the football
being delivered to bite and i was like
oh come on you guys
well let me read some of this they say
this uh it's happened before a seamless
transition of power in the case of
unexpected events is a hallmark of a
functioning democracy
biden is healthy and vaccinated but
given his age it's responsible to ask
what happens if he gets ill while in
office or worse dies
after all that has happened to a
remarkable 17 percent of us presidents 8
out of 46.
in 1941 william william henry harrison
died of typhoid
at 68. in 1850 zachary taylor
died at 66 possibly of cholera in 1865
abraham lincoln was assassinated by john
john wilkes booth james garfield
was also assassinated in 1881 at the age
of 48 by charles
gutteau a lawyer who believed he
deserved a reward for helping the
president's election
interesting william mckinley who died at
58 1901 also assassinated
by anarchist leon charles gauss i didn't
know that i don't know we had that many
assassinations yeah that's crazy
warren uh let's see uh warren harding
died of a heart attack in 1923
and was not as it was rumored at the
time poisoned by his wife florence
franklin delano roosevelt died at six at
the age of 63
poor health and john f kennedy he got
his head blown off
who's next the 25th amendment of the
constitution which deals with
presidential vacancy disability or
inability is clear on what happens if
the president dies
resigns or is removed removed or is
removed
ah yes this one this this one
do they go on to mention the uh the
commission
the line of succession uh established in
the 1947 presidential succession act
starts with speaker of the house nancy
pelosi
okay they're saying what happens if both
the president and vice president are
unable to serve
so it goes nancy pelosi and then it goes
chuck grassley
and then it goes demo then after chuck
grassley the president pro tempe
it will be democratic senator pat leahy
of vermont oh no i'm sorry no he would
be pro tempe
and the then cabinet members starting
with secretary of state
however the presidential succession act
says officials beyond the vice president
in line of succession would only be
acting as president
not become president after resigning
from their office
they will only hold the office until a
new president can be chosen
blah blah blah we get the point the
media is going to start ramping up this
kind of rhetoric because
it's responsible to ask joe biden's 14
years
older than his life expectancy for his
generation
so yeah president kamala who did you
pick as vp if that's the case
hillary good lord and then and then and
then kamala has a
unfortunate accident yes and then
hillary becomes president and the circle
is complete yes you know i have a tweet
in 2018 that's just sitting there
waiting to get brought up
it's it's kamala harris will never be
president mark it down
and uh it's becoming even uh it's
becoming clear that that that's
at risk it's good that you embrace it
though i'm embracing
don't run from it i'm not running from
the tweet but man kamala harris
presidency
sounds terrifying to me effectively what
do we have now anyway i mean it's
getting all the same policies all the
same procedures all the same appointees
all the same crap i said i thought
kamala harris was going to be president
at one point
and then tulsi gabbard you know nuked
her campaign and so maybe that will end
up coming true to a certain degree
i will take credit for my a completely
accurate prediction which no one saw
coming
that joe biden would be inaugurated
without a hitch and
it was crazy because so many people were
like i don't know man
i'm hearing this stuff and i'm like dude
nine i said 99.99999 percent chance
joe biden is going to get inaugurated
after the election there was like
i gave it like a three to five percent
chance trump pulled something off
because the lawsuits didn't happen yet
and then after the lawsuits failed i was
like it's gonna it's gonna be joe biden
it's it's it's trump against the
establishment the cronies he's got no
allies
he's got his supporters that's great
it's a lot of people and that's about it
the republicans don't like him they want
him gone and that's why i think they
might actually convict him
in the senate they might they might say
well interaction is a very serious thing
and this country must get back on track
in order to unify we're going to vote
with our democratic counterparts
and that's it trump can't run again in
2024
convicted of inciting insurrection i
keep hearing that the republican party
is trying to scrub
trump and all the signs of trump out of
the party do you guys think that's what
they're doing
do you think it's a good idea of course
they will yeah yeah but you know you
know what i love the most
joe biden is going to be inheriting
quite a budget crunch from president
trump
yeah that's what lisa simpson said in
the simpsons episode where she becomes
president
we've inherited quite a budget crunch
from president trump
and then trump got elected and the
deficit increased
and the debt increased and now there's
biden but it's okay because
the budget crunch is meaningless when
money printer go birth
it just means that you the american
citizen will see your buying power
diminish
i hope you've been paying attention to
your ability to buy uh foreign goods
so you know what people don't seem to
understand about the minimum wage
and economics is that trade within your
you know trading block your country or
whatever
can be fairly static because if you're
going to trade with someone next door
like
let's say your neighbor's got you know
eggs they've got much fresh eggs and
then you're like i've got some freshly
chopped wood you're gonna there you have
a kind of understanding on how much work
you would be willing to do
when we see inflation in this country
it's going to change the way we import
goods from other countries
because that's where the the change is
going is going to really really impact
you
which is why computer components have
been skyrocketing in cost
so i've been we've been trying to do a
bunch of i.t stuff and we've been
getting hit with
you know certain computer components i
think motherboards may have gone way up
you want to build a computer it's
getting harder you want to buy a tablet
the price is already up 30 40
that's happening right now not to
mention wow dude is property
skyrocketing
we are on track to be like ukraine where
a ton of ultra wealthy corporations and
individuals will hold the majority of
the wealth
and regular people will be desperate and
unable to pay their bills
what's really amazing about ukraine is
that my assumption
when i when i've been i've been there
several times i have friends there was
that
property must be really cheap for an
american you know
they're they're oh how did we lose
connection that's weird
of all the times to lose connection that
makes no sense because we have great
internet
but i'll continue the story anyway so i
assumed that
uh property would be cheap because
the america the exchange rate for a
dollar to the is
probably pronouncing it terribly is uh
really really high it's getting higher
and higher and higher especially with
the the the instability
and no turns out if you want to get
property in
kiev it's comparable to american prices
why because oligarchs run the country
so and we're back for whatever that was
weird
so anyway long story short when you have
a country that functions very much like
silicon valley the ultra wealthy are
rich will always be rich and they
control the flow of money
the poor people will never never make
enough enough to buy property ever again
and that will maintain the oligarchy and
that's where we're going to right now
the mass printing of money will make it
so that regular people will never own
anything and doesn't that sound familiar
in the future by 2030 you'll own nothing
and you'll be happy
yeah you'll love it i mean we clearly
live in an oligarchy today a uniparty
the corporations are oligopoly
oligopolists they're they're working in
there it's a cabal
at this point basically right well let's
not be negative nancy's let's let's i
think we should take some time and
appreciate the good things that biden
and harris are really great at
i would like to start off and say that
they're really good at jailing people
for victimless crimes
and they're very effective gotta jail
someone yeah yeah
and and it's going to be pretty boring
soon coming up as well luke luke
yes listen let's go at least we've got
that going for us let's be honest here
these poor private prison companies
their bottom line is at risk
look if people aren't being incarcerated
then how will they maintain corporate
profits
yeah what else is the
military-industrial complex supposed to
do
hey look man look there are a lot of
kids running around over that middle
east yes someone's got to blow them up
fire up the drones morbidium oh my gosh
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you